construction at the Obama Presidential
Center in Chicago has been temporarily
halted after a noose was discovered at
the work site there are two possible
explanations for why people keep finding
ropes on construction sites one is that
the construction industry one of the
most racially diverse Industries in the
country with at least a third of all
workers being Hispanic is also infested
somehow with white supremacists sure
yeah that makes sense the other possible
reason why there are ropes on
construction sites is that a
construction site is a construction site
perhaps you find ropes there for the
same reason you find Hammers and nails
and lumber
why don't you explain this to me like
I'm five
if you're going to immediately assume
that a rope on a construction site is
meant to send a racist message you may
as well immediately assume that a bucket
of black paint is intended to be to be
used for black face or something
you have jumped to the most extreme and
bizarre conclusion and in the process
you have leapt right over simpler and
more banal and more obvious and more
innocent ones